hey guys it's Friday October 21st I'm
Mary and if this site hasn't been d das
yet you're watching gamespot's top five
news stories of the week first up a
couple of my buddies got engaged in
destiny today and I'm stealing this
first spot to congratulate them couple
of dorky lovebirds Vlambeer Rami Ishmael
who you might remember from his game
nuclear throne and adriel Wallach who
formerly worked at firehose games to
help out together with the indie
megabusa shared the news on Twitter
today Wallach proposed in destiny using
several pieces of custom content put
together by Bungie this included a
special emote that let her go down on
one knee an artifact train called ring
of eternity and a letter from the
postmaster that pops a question
congratulations Romney and adriel may
you fill the destiny servers with your
beautiful babies and now for some sad
news if you wanted to play Sleeping Dogs
to you might be waiting for a really
long time it looks like the developer is
shut down Sleeping Dogs developer united
front games has closed its doors the
vancouver-based studio was in the midst
of developing smash and grab which was
an early access game on steam that
featured players ransacking stores and
looting items as of now smash and grab
can't be purchased on Steam it was just
free this past weekend as part of a
promotion on Steam where players could
pay a discounted price of 17 bucks to
keep playing after Sunday it's unclear
what's going to happen to smash and grab
and its players we've contacted united
front and we're going to keep you
updated when we hear back doesn't look
like we'll be playing Sleeping Dogs to
anytime soon thanks for the memories
united front games turns out yelling at
someone over and over again for what you
want does work at least an overwatch
hooray overwatch is Halloween update
introduced a bunch of awesome new skins
let's give some extra attention to that
excellent which skin for mercy damn girl
like that skin but sadly it doesn't
cause her to use the new voice line
that's present
the new bra mode mursi's ultimate voice
line heroes never die was replaced with
my servants never die fast forward to
some four hundred ninety plus posts
later players petitioning for an
inclusion have received a simple answer
from game director Jeff Kaplan okay he
said ETA mid-november what a cool guy
this only encourages me more to play
play play the limited time Halloween
event and unlock those sweet sweet skins
Rockstar Games shook the gaming world
this week after a couple teasers they
announced red dead redemption to check
out these cryptic tweets we had to deal
with these for four days before Rockstar
unveiled the trailer for red dead
redemption to the video doesn't tell us
a lot but we do get to look at the games
vastly improved graphics and some
gorgeous scenery in terms of story we
don't really get a good look at what
appears to be the main characters face
but a dude who sounds like such from the
original red dead redemption does say
listen to me
when the time comes you gotta run and
don't look back this is over there are
seven characters seen at the end of the
trailer it only shows their cowboy butts
we don't know who they are all we know
is what rock star has told us which is
it's an epic tale of life in America's
unforgiving heartland the game's vast
and Atmospheric world will also provide
the foundation for a brand new online
multiplayer experience red dead
redemption to has been announced for
playstation 4 and xbox one in fall of
2017 there was no info about a PC
release sorry and for our top news story
of the week do you ever feel like your
real life gets in the way of your gaming
do you ever want to play NBA 2k 17 while
watching basketball or play mario kart
while driving well do I have the console
for you get a look at switch the highly
anticipated new console from Nintendo
it's just five months before it's
supposed to launch as rumored it's a
console handheld hybrid that uses
cartridges this console is senpai in the
streets and hentai in the sheets in the
home Nintendo switch sits in the
Nintendo switch dock that connects to a
TV you can then lift the system out of
the dock and it will instantly
transition into a portable mode just
look at this woman who needs to go to a
party but she also wants to play a video
game now she can make that appearance
but still not talk to anyone the power
of technology is working the detachable
controllers that sit on either side of
the Nintendo switch are called joy con
controllers you can attach these
controllers to the system itself or a
grip accessory alternatively the whole
thing can be used wirelessly Nintendo
showed off a lot of games on switch
including Skyrim NBA 2k The Legend of
Zelda breath of the wild and Mario Kart
and most intriguingly what looked like a
new 3d Mario game let's see that game
enhance we don't know very much about
the specs just yet and what I'm most
curious about battery life you'll have
to stay tuned to gamespot for the latest
on that but Nintendo has confirmed two
things it's slated to launch in March
2017
and it will be able to play the legend
of zelda breath of the wild and that's
all the news I have for you this week
your regularly scheduled host Jess
McDonald will be back again on Monday
with more newsy goodness I'll see you
guys again later bye